This narration here,
this narration has many aspects of it
which
bolster and work towards
The point of this chapter and the
chapter theme, the theme of the chapter
is truthfulness, sincerity, tress. What
is inside matches what is outside. What
is said matches what is believed. This
here, this narration has many themes to
it and it has many points and many
lessons in it. However,
many aspects of it point to this
theme and that is the effect
of truthfulness and trness which is why
mentions it.
This narration
is an authentic narration. Actually,
it's of the highest levels of
authenticity. It's collected by both
Bkari and Muslim and it is
about one of the prophets of Benny is
after MS and Harunat.
most of the scholars who explain this
narration identify this prophet as
Yah.
Yun
is the person who is mentioned in the
Quran that Benu is came to when they
requested a king be appointed so that
they could go for jihad
in Bakar and in the story of
and Jalut. And so this narration here
speaks about
one of these battles of
or this prophet of ben is
that our prophet sallall.aii wasallam
tells us of
the prophet sallall.aii Wasallam says
that one of the prophets
went
was preparing his people to take them
to battle to lead them into battle. And
he said to his people,
"No man amongst you who has married a
woman who has not consummated his
marriage with her yet and is still in
anticipation
of consummating his marriage with her.
If that is your description, then you
are not to accompany us in this battle."
He says, "And no man amongst you
who has built
any buildings or structures and has
not completed the roof on said
structures and seeing these building
ventures to their ends and they are
still in the process of doing that.
None, none of you who is of such
description is to accompany us. Nor
anyone who has livestock.
And you know, there's a season for
livestock. A season when the animals are
in heat and it's a mating season. And
then there is a season when these
newborns start to be born. That's a
very exciting season for people who
you know are are in that business. And
it's a very big thing. I don't know if
if anyone here has been exposed to that,
but when I was a child,
we had, you know, people in our family
had livestock and so forth. that when it
was coming close to the time when the
livestock was going to be born,
we would go and sleep actually in the
pen with the the
you know the cows or the sheep or
whatever it is that we're waiting on to
be there at a moment's notice. Our very
beduin form of being on call for the
birthing of these animals. It's a very
important thing. if you're not there,
things could happen. You could lose a
lot of money. It could be the difference
between a fruitful season and not
so fruitful. And so the point is is that
he says that any of you who has married
a woman and has is still anticipating
consummation, any of you who is in the
midst of building and has not completed
and finished those ventures, any of you
who has livestock and is waiting for
the delivery of this these these
newborns. What is he saying? Anyone who
is going to go with me to battle
and his heart is going to be back here
back home while he just gives me his
body. Don't bother coming. We only want
men who are as the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam described our prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. He described them
as
the platoon of death. those men who are
going anticipating
martyrdom and are going to be very
disappointed if they have to come back
home. Those are the men that we want
with us. We don't want people that are
going to come with us,
take up our resources,
clutter our midst, and break up our
gatherings with their cowardice,
and their hearts and their true
intentions and tress is back home. Their
body is just with us as if they're doing
us a favor. If that is the if that is
the case, please stay back. Not one
person who is in that situation is to
come with me. Right? And we're always
seeing this as the portrayal of the good
soldiers, you know, the the the you
know, the soldier has a little picture
of Mary Sue and this is my gal, you
know, and I'm I'm going back home and
and we're going to go eat cheeseburgers
together. This is not a soldier. A
soldier who accompanies prophets. They
are as Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala said.
[Silence]
So these men who accompanied the
prophets into battle, they are the best
of men. They are the men who are going
to paradise. They see themselves on the
on the stoop of the gates of
paradise. And if they can't get in this
time to paradise, they are going to be
very disappointed. Their heart is
already ahead of us on the battlefield.
many of us probably have heard would
send in his letters on occasion
to his enemies before he would arrive
with the mighty
with the mighty armies of Islam that
I'm coming to you with men who love
death as much as you all love life.
Those are the kinds of men that are to
accompany me in this battle. And so this
is in order to
thin out the fodder
to thin out what we call the cannon
fodder. We don't need them in our midst
in this battlefield.
And this is not just the situation with
this prophet and messenger. the
companions
in the battles of as well made
similar requests to their generals. We
will discuss that tomorrow inshallah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala.
This is a lengthy narration. We want to
take our time with it. So it'll probably
take a day or two to complete a day or
two more
subala
and